you talk about weird stories so you're a
young girl
um you know it becomes apparent that
you're very good looking and your
friends
did a trick on you yeah well Frenemies
you're in uh is this in high school
would you say how old were you at this
point 16 16. I could drive yes uh you
get a call from a local department store
they say hey Cindy you're a beautiful
girl we'd love for you to come to the
department store and model and and uh
this is a great break for a girl where
were you living you were living in town
yeah in Illinois and it's exciting
that's how you get into the modeling
business out of nowhere so I was like
wow like someone must have noticed me
walking down Main Street you know and
you probably went to your parents and
said hey I'm going down to the local
department store they've asked me to
model and you're excited and your hopes
and dreams are coming true and you get
to the store in the store I guess you
walk into the store and you say it's
from here to model and they look at you
like you're crazy
and it turned out your friends pulled a
prank on you your so-called friends
pulled a prank on you they called your
house pretended to be the department
store that had a hurt oh I literally I
can still remember that feeling of just
my
I mean first of all I ran out of that
store as quick as I could because I just
was mortified and then I saw these two
girls like half a block away standing on
the corners laughing
and it was it was so mean it did hurt it
hurt a lot but
later
I've been able to tap into that you know
like huh I guess I showed them you know
well you said every time you went on a
modeling job and the bigger the modeling
jobs got you think of those two girls
doing that prank what is that does that
relax you in a way or does it say [ __ ]
you I'm going to be the greatest model
I'm gonna make the most money out of
anything that's F you it does yeah and I
saw them at my tenure High School
reunion too do they and do they walk up
and and uh you know and suck up to you
incredibly because you're now the famous
Cindy Crawford uh they just know to stay
away
you know it's like what do they say
success is the greatest Revenge right I
don't have to say anything